you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I'm playing a 5-2 game against
Sophia Rodgers all right we have a
Sicilian let's see let's try yeah let's
play Knight c3 I was considering c3 and
then d4 but I think I already have a
couple games in there like that so let's
try something a little bit different
let's go with a king sized fianchetto
delaying d4 it's a cup Bishop g2 Castle
can't prevent d4 so well you could but
waste some time and you weaken d5 so I
think in the end I'm still gonna play
this yeah I don't see how I could really
do without d4 I want to be able to move
this Knight
so the bishop is one step closer to
seeing the Queen side squares there may
be possibilities of captures in the knee
five breaking up this group of three
pawns okay so Bishop e3 have to be a
little bit concerned about a knight
dropping into c4 let's avoid this Knight
exchange for the moment and maybe I
could even look forward to a g4 g5 idea
pretty committal move but if I do get
this in the bishop on d7 is getting in
the way of nighty-night here so it's
pretty committal I realized but let's go
with the g4
I want to avoid a minor piece exchange I
didn't want to allow this bishop to
easily access the c6 square 95 I could
give the knight a kick and he has to go
here I think it's best that I keep my
Bishop on c1 because of this idea of a
Knight a5 into C 495 into c4 where he
would then strike it be - so I guess
preparing me g5 with Knight h5 let's not
be so quick to chase this Knight to a4
word square but that for probably king
h1 is a useful move Queen beats b6 can
hit with check at any moment Knight a5
into c4 Knight a5 I don't know if I
really want to take and allow them to
develop mmm that's a pretty sharp move
if I take there's Queen b6 okay on the
other hand suppose I play Bishop here
right now let's let's actually get
developed and I have an idea in mind of
that after Knight a5 I could take and
then consider a5 chasing the night away
and then taking advantage of this Bishop
doing alright on the clock don't know
why I didn't at least consider that move
okay I don't think I really have a good
square other than e2 Oh actually on e2 I
dropped this pawn not cool hmm do I have
to play Knight to d5 too loose piece
there hmm
I am hitting d6 okay yeah things are
gonna get sharp maybe 90
five maybe H five within Knight g4 ideas
I think on H five a play ch3 and alright
striking it the night I think I have to
go here yeah can't just drop that pond
there's gonna be some strike I think
against G for Knight takes Knight takes
and then II five or just that right away
interesting okay well let's take first
and I have to do something about this
pawn queen d3 runs into Bishop b5 hmm
how about I take and play Bishop g5 I
might need to do that you know I don't
think I have time to defend here Queen
d3 Bishop b5 alright and I think I am
I'm kind of forced into this move okay
let's see there is still this check I
don't like that it's an open position
and my King is vulnerable to Bishop
checks or Queen checks like Knight a5
moves are ruled out of course Queen b6
are they defending this tonight do they
have to play King g7 hmm interesting
okay
you have to watch over g4 no wonder what
candidate moves to consider queenie -
there's once again Bishop b5 this is a
dead piece Queen d2 with Bishop h6 stuff
I think Queen d2 rook da tis a fine
reply Queen f3
maybe maybe Queen f3 is a move hmm
Bishop take so take the knight Knight
takes I take the bishop for there isn't
a good discovery I think I could do this
let's see just trying to crash through
on the f6 and f7 squares that's a check
and I just probably have to scoot out of
the way here yeah I could play Bishop e3
but I want to keep pressure here so the
Queen is there to defend the knight
potentially we have exactly that hmm I
still want to keep pressure on that
night now let's do this if I could get
my knight into play that would be nice
but it takes forever I'm in at 27 an ID
to f1 III d5 ye oh that's a lot of moves
alright I think I have to go here now
react and at least throw a punch
maybe Knight a5 or night c5 depending on
where the Queen goes I wonder how good
my Bishop is on g2 should I look to
reroute it
ah maybe I could do that actually I'd
love to seat Bishop takes Bishop so I
could triple up I don't know how good it
is I'm Bishop c6 Bishop d3 is my idea I
think I was close to a mouse slipped
there now I don't like that my king is
on this diagonal who they're firing away
there I think I could play Knight here
or actually what about this yeah I think
they missed that move Knight a5 and
that's me the light square bishop yeah
Bishop takes pawn I take the Queen okay
so I'm not too worried about the light
squares I'm fine with my King in the
corner now I'm gonna be playing with the
bishop pair and I like my position now
because of this move grabbing the light
square bishop I guess Queen c7 or Queen
d7 are they really calculating a capture
here okay let's get that guy get my last
piece working he's kind of a dummy
maybe b3 and Bishop c4 each for g5 can
eventually kick the night hmm tough
position this guy is really a strictly
defensive piece right now so I'd like to
reroute him to a more active post like
d5 that would I'd be a fine square my
queen has some responsibility of
defending g4 I should probably keep an
eye out for Bishop takes h6 ideas or
maybe even a direct g5 move I don't know
if I want to play b3 just yet
yeah let's let's keep this let's bring
it to a point where I'm at least one
move away from operating on a new dog
and I'll pinpointing pinpointing f7 I
may be able to do a queen sac here let's
just get a quick move in kingi - seems
like a nice spot for my king interesting
move
maybe this was - hmm I don't know -
quiet are too passive too much of a
nothing move okay I really feel like
sacking and I think I'm going to yeah it
feels right I'm gonna get a lot of
material and I think their King will
still have some problems so let's scoop
up the fish up and there's maybe even
Bishop takes h6 so he's still gluing
things together I think I had pretty
good coordination I'm prepared to take
out the knight should he arrive here -
Rick - Rick's versus the Queen
there's Bishop c4 as well to be a bit
careful it's coming down to the wire
here 33 seconds 30 both of us under 30
just pile up two pigs here rook g7 maybe
take h6 rook takes Bishop pawn takes
yeah they're gonna go for that I don't
have anything better
hmm
how about King here and then rook c1
trying to get to the eighth-ranked rook
c1 is that would be attacking the Queen
oh you know what I missed
there's Knight g6 oops oops oops oops
it's still gonna try for that yeah they
have Knight g5 mm-hmm there's Knight c3
as well yeah this holidays is a
perpetual probably gonna go for more
draw wow what a tough game very tight I
missed this idea when I stepped up with
the king
alright good game I wonder if this was
still working this Queen sac as usual I
want to just review it some what do they
say in that sure if there was anything
at the end yeah I'm wondering if there
maybe could take on h3 and then look to
get back into a g5 yeah they're saying a
crazy one it definitely was a little bit
crazy there okay let me have a look at
it without the evaluation first off and
without the arrows and let's see yeah I
have to play d4 I don't think there's
any great reason to delay it but I don't
know just get the quick Bishop g2
castles moves in and I don't know I
guess g4 is an idea but it's certainly
committal
Bishop III I think I'm worse right
around here and maybe I should have
stopped before although no on a three
there's still this I can't take on b5
because of Queen b6 hmm yeah I think I
just have to be prepared to find a new
square for my knight and maybe maybe
even right here I wonder if this is too
soon
King h1 and that actually feels a little
too slow
King h1 with the idea to then playoff
for that way b5 can't hit so soon
I don't know maybe the computer I'll
have a different suggestion right around
here because when things open up like
this you certainly don't want to be the
one who has an open King mmm even just
this one open dog and I'll it's tricky
and I'm pretty locked in to this
variation I believe at least and maybe
even black could have done one better
here with instead of e5 switching the
move order with this and then after I
take back yeah I think that this is a
better idea for black to take first
instead of e5 to take and then I don't
know bishop or Knight probably the night
because he's kind of stupid on v3 then
e5 and then this is a big problem so
they just switch the move order I think
I'm in big trouble here Knight takes g4
I forget about it
bishops kicked off of this dog you know
enter Queen b6 my king is vulnerable I'm
down upon yeah and my King remains
vulnerable so I'm pretty sure Knight
takes would have been better for black
and then I have to go in for this
because there's not a convenient way to
defend efore Queen d3 Bishop b5 Queen
here is not defending
and this smooth I don't know Queen b6
going v7 piling up here I thought I
needed to take and be quite direct -
yeah it's tight game and yeah they
missed that so probably I don't know
first rook here or maybe even look to
kick my knight away some hmm I don't
know this is where they went astray so
I'm guessing there's something better
here for black
I don't know this seems pretty sensible
work to dat probably want to keep the
rookie or defending f7 so move this rook
probably here no it's a tough call very
tight game felt like I'm back in it here
the preferred side and then maybe I
should be doing something different than
h3 huh I don't know I'm just kind of
consolidating here with h3 and Kingi too
so this will really be the last thing to
look at I'm not sure what I missed how I
could have done better but we're gonna
find out and could I have done better
here yeah it seems like Knight g5 is
just there in time to stop me from
getting active against their king and
this was probably a wise choice to take
out the bishop as otherwise I'm getting
another rook here I have good
coordination removed the removed part of
the glue here well the main the main
piece that is gluing my position
together is the bishop they remove that
so this would be the last thing to
really check out the computer okay let's
let's actually do that right now here's
the graph at one point they had a pawn
and a half advantage okay let's put the
evaluation on and kind of skim through
it here doing a little bit of a blunder
check even ish what's with this g4 is it
okay to do g4 let's see
fan of it but it's not bad Queenie -
instead okay have forests popping up
it's an idea g4f far okay wants to
insert ha3 this is what I was wondering
a three a five and then okay interesting
you know one way to reason this by
inserting a three I maintain my night
position and if a five is played
insisting still on before noticed that
this is at least taking away square from
both the knight and queen not sure that
the Queen really want to play there but
I know it reference during the game that
there might be this reroute to see for
for the moment at least this is no
longer a possibility if we insert a
three and a five so with this in mind I
think I would now be a bit more inclined
to play a three and you know another way
to view it I mean why not do this in the
event B four does hit at least I have
the option of like to capture first
strike so to speak I could initiate a
capture okay if I could do it over again
I think I would be leaning a bit more
towards a three to maintain my c3 post I
went on with development and I got a
plain IP five might be one no way 92
they could take on g4 so I went into p5
and now it's really liking team black
hmm because I have to go into that
and it like cg5 this is where I was
thinking first take night takes and now
he 500k so we have to start going with
very concrete line G 594 wool in the
knight to c6 yeah
yeah that's pretty sharp I'd say huh oh
yeah
that's really really sharp Bishop takes
Knight Queen takes Knight Knight takes
Bishop Knight takes Queen yeah that's
that's getting pretty sophisticated I
would say okay you have a very critical
line without question so they they hit
with e5 and g5
I'm not just dropping this pawn if I
play g5 sharp stuff man 95 takes okay
let's still go with takes here and then
Bishop their Queen b6 check clean b6
King in the corner and then Bishop here
hmm that's tricky
this was a really tight game King g7
Queen f3 its back to even now Bishop b5
oh and they could take there's a
tactical shot so that's why it was
coming up about upon of Han and 1/2 in
the graph because of this shot right
here the Knight takes e4 mmm both missed
this one huh Bishop takes Bishop and
they takes rook
Queen takes Knight Bishop takes Bishop
and then top six
oh yeah I'm here we could you could do
rook takes Bishop because the Queen has
pressure on the bishop okay that would
have been a nice shot and now it likes
me
pawn and a half advantage with Bishop
takes h6 hmm what's the story with this
King takes all man luring the King out
clean check rook takes Bishop takes oh
yeah these quiet moves Queen here stuff
oh that that's pretty sharp there I
didn't consider that I know he's
pointing it out during the game maybe
there's something in mind with this but
I didn't see this follow up ID of g5
mm-hmm okay we both missed some tactics
that it that idea is still there with
Bishop takes h6 just went in for Knight
a5 and now okay yeah Bishop takes h6
right here you know didn't see the idea
mm-hmm just keeps calling out for this
chop chop g5 and this idea of
controlling the dark squares my bishop
could control the light squares and then
the rooks can help out maybe here there
okay yeah wow that would have been a
really nice shot okay
didn't see it every
every move it's calling out for Bishop
takes h6 alright and this is winning
rook takes is best and on Queen check I
have to play rook f2 and this is in fact
turning out to be a draw I have to play
king g2 here
what don't I just drop my bishop oh I
guess the idea is this perpetual with
the rook going back and forth here ah
okay I should have played in this final
position not in this final position but
I should have played rook f2 Queen takes
pawn and Bishop takes Queen takes pawn
check King h2 yo+ for Queen c6 there's a
check Wow
yeah you know if I could have just
spotted that knight move as soon as he
entered the Queen Knight combo against
my king that's too much
I'm glad it was an okay sacrifice but
yeah I needed to calculate better here
instead of stepping up I was just
thinking here there and they have to
block has to go on the defensive but
Knight g5 am I losing at some point here
Knight c3 and takes I guess it's still
even but yeah this is pretty scary with
my King exposed and I don't quite have
the coordination I would want here I was
thinking that they could capture here
then go back take their yeah I have to
do
something different right around here oh
you know on this night h3 check I have
to play over here attack the night now
that he's no longer around here to help
out defending against these mating ideas
yeah I have this King G to move King f8
rook here
I still have ideas Queen check I'm gonna
have to be very accurate if I take the
knight they take my bishop and then take
my rook let's check so I'd have to go to
the corner yeah I bet you black would've
caught me because I have to be extra
careful with where I go with my king
yeah but I guess with the best play in
this unbalanced end game to Brooks
versus the Queen I have to uh well it's
even with best play interesting you know
very tight game first time playing
against this opponent here Sofia Rogers
alright
as usual feel free to leave any feedback
to this video in the comment section
below and I'll catch you in the next one
that's all for now take care bye